-Your daughter, 8-years-old.
-8-years-old now.
-Halloween coming up.
-Does she have plans?
-She has huge plans.
She has picked
a very elaborate costume
that we´re gonna -- we´re still
trying to put together
that she told me -- she goes,
"I know you´re going on TV.
Don´t say my costume!"
-Okay, great.
-Like, you guys
will blog about it or something.
You know.
[ Laughter ]
But the thing about --
Every year, her friend --
She has this friend
who goes to this
very progressive hippie school
in Los Feliz, where --
It´s the kind of school
where it´s like,
"We don´t have walls."
And like, "Instead of
an A or an F,
we give a sticker
of a smiling pomegranate
or a worried opossum."
Like, "Wait. What?" you know.
But they do this really cool
Halloween carnival every year.
And they --
and the kids -- these --
you know, grade-school kids,
put together a haunted house.
And it´s so charming.
You go in, and they have --
They make hallways
out of trash bags,
and you go down the hall
and something jumps, "Boo!"
and the kids -- "Aah!"
It´s just -- and I´ve --
I´ve taken my daughter
since she was 3,
and she just jumps in my arms
and hides her head,
but I can hear her laughing.
She´s like -- thinks she --
It´s hilarious for her to be
scared by this silly thing.
But the last year we went,
I don´t know why this happened.
The adults
at the school decided,
"We are going to help
do the haunted house."
So I go in with Alice, and
there´s a bunch of other kids,
and the first thing
that happens, we walked in,
and this woman
dressed like a witch
pops out and says,
"I´ve killed Harry Potter!"
[ Laughter ]
And all of the kids go, "What?!"
and just, like, start crying.
And then she has to start going,
"No, but what happened was,
he used an amulet to save --
You´ll see at the end."
Like, she has to then tell the
whole story of the haunted --
So instead of, like,
a fun haunted house
with werewolves and ghosts,
it was, we walked in,
and then adults just pitched
bad movie sequels to us.
[ Laughter ]
"I guess, uh..."
[ Applause ]
And what really, really
bummed me out was,
the first year I took Alice
through the haunted house
at the school,
I saw the scariest thing
I´ve ever seen by accident.
Because, you know, again,
you go down these halls
and stuff pops out.
So I turn the last corner,
and, you know, that´s where
you go, then the exit,
this long hallway.
And when I turn the corner,
at the end of --
at the end of the hallway,
as I turn,
a kindergartner had gotten lost.
And the kindergartner
was wearing, like,
an adult monster mask,
and on it´s tilted on his head.
So it´s this giant head
and this little body,
and he´s standing
under a red light bulb.
So I turned the corner,
and there´s just
this little like...thing,
[ Laughter ]
like, at the end of this hall.
Like, I --
I [bleep] my pants off.
Like, that´s -- Like, boom!
It was so...
[ Applause ]
I´ve never gotten over that.
It was so terrifying.
-Well, I hope you have
a less terrifying Halloween.
Always great to see you, buddy.